في الولايات المتحدة ، لا توجد حالات معروفة
لمرض فيروس ماربورغ والخطر الحالي
منخفض ولكن مركز السيطرة على الأمراض يحذر
الأطباء من أن يكونوا على اطلاع على أي شخص
لديه أعراض فيروس ماربورغ ينتمي إلى
نفس عائلة فيروس الإيبولا
ويمكن أن يسبب  تقول
الدكتورة كريستين إنجلاند من
كليفلاند كلينيك إن المرض شديد الخطورة ومميت ، يقول إن المرض
ليس معديًا حتى تظهر الأعراض ،
ويمكن أن تشمل الحمى ، والصداع ، وآلام
المفاصل ، والإرهاق ، وفقدان الشهية ،
ومشاكل الجهاز الهضمي ، والنزيف غير المبرر
في الوقت الحالي ،
تم التعرف على تفشي فيروس ماربورغ فقط في
دولتين أفريقيتين.  دولتي غينيا الاستوائية
وتنزانيا يقول مركز السيطرة على الأمراض إنه لا يوجد
دليل على أن الفاشيتين مرتبطان بأن
الناس يمكن أن يصعدوا على متن طائرات يمكن للناس السفر ،
ومن السهل جدًا الانتقال من
جزء من العالم إلى آخر اليوم في
مارس ، كما حذرت مراكز مكافحة الأمراض والوقاية منها المسافرين إلى
البلدين إلى  تجنب الاتصال
بالمرضى ومراقبة صحتهم
لمدة ثلاثة أسابيع بعد زيارة
فيروس ماربورغ يمكن أن ينتشر من خلال ملامسة
دم الشخص المصاب وسوائل الجسم الأخرى
أو من خلال سوائل
الحيوانات المصابة لا ينتشر عبر
الهواء مثل فيروس كورونا الذي نحتاج إليه جميعًا
كن على دراية بعدم الخوف ولكن بالتأكيد على دراية
بما هو موجود في الدقيقة الصحية ،
أنا آندي غايثر